we continue with my on counting
hypergraph colorings in the local
lamellar regime
thank you since thanks for the
organizers Matheny just really nice
backing is also I could before the talk
let me um advertiser recently result of
money and which is actually quite
related to the last talk so we gave some
kind of optimum mixing higher bond for
these low rents and distributions
improving upon break through a lot and
re at all but yeah this is a randomized
counting so I will not talk about this
today o instead talk about honking happy
well colorings and I have a sort of two
motivations to talk about this firstly
that the method the algorithm is one
that haven't been covered in this
workshop yet so this is a basically
Moltres method and it's the simplest
accounting and way we actually don't
understand it there well we don't know
how to relate this to existing matters
like correlation decay or equal to zero
the second of motivation of mine is that
the problem yourself I think it's very
interesting and we can prove something
from non trivial it's not very
satisfying and I hope to stimulate some
interest in studying the problem and
maybe we can see an answer one day okay
so yeah so this is joy to work with note
on the control from Shanghai Jiaotong
University and also Duke here from China
University of finance economics of
within the audience let's start with the
colorings okay we believe the most you
know this so this is a pictorial
definition of colorings and whenever I
say coloring I mean proper coloring so I
want different colors for every a decent
health versus okay and I also talked
about some kind of computational
compactly phase foundation I think this
is very well known in for all these so I
would not spend too much time on this
and the by computational complexity
phase relation with hemay is when the
some parameters change the problem the
compact
the problem also change drastically so
some toy example is that the problem of
deciding whether the graph is Q
colorable of funder coloring even exists
so apparently this is a trivial if Q is
1 2 you have 2 colors then is just test
whether it's baptized or not but when Q
is at least 3 the problem suddenly jumps
to and be hard so this is not so
interesting and the slightly more
interesting case is when you have a
degree bomb
it's let's say I'm talking about graphs
with maximum degree Delta and of course
when the number of colors here is
sufficiently large that is easy the
solved problem you just do a great
algorithm right and you're actually
calls started below Delta plus 1/2
roughly Delta minus square root Delta
well you can still be solve the
important time due to a result by law in
the read and if you code someone below
is where how the problem jumps to and be
hard to use your early result by abdomen
nerds
hole guardian future so I probably
pronounced it terrible it wrong so yes
this piece of the Syrian burden of
coloring is very well understood even in
the upon de tigre case but of course our
program is about counting and I will
talk about approximate counting mostly
so approximate contents of a uniform
sampling are closely related and
especially in these regimes because of
several disability they are actually the
same problem so how can we generate a
uniform proper coloring also efficiently
again these are there some already
success is due to the Markov chain Monte
Carlo approached by Jeremy and
independently thousand so called this
showed that the corporate dynamics is
rapid mixing when Q is at least two
doubt so corporate dynamics is one where
you at every step you randomly pick a
vertex and a recolor it and this was
improved by the goda to rough like them
over six Delta
um he showed more complicated dynamics
called a long swanson koat s key
dynamics in wrapped in mixing and this -
that is the best result for like almost
20 years and here very recently I'll
call the improvement through the two
groups of people independently o chant
mantra and also they're called the
prayer oh no and posture so they improve
this to have more six money it's a very
small absalom the absalom is something
like ten to the minus four say but the
the conceptual message is that this is
not a barrier and on the other hand we
have any hardness if q is lessened out
of this is due to Kalani's the bank of H
and Bogota but for some technical
reasons this only works for even Q but
you don't really expect all people to be
different so the question really is
where you the fare hold what is the
truth so the contractor is there to this
fair hold is there plus one and this is
actually a star hold of uniqueness of
keys mirrors in infinite Delta regular
tree so basically the contactor is that
whenever it behaves nicely on if into
regular tree it should we should have
always among any Delta Ponte de Graaff
really what happens here is that when Q
is the other past one this example is a
have degree 3 and 4 colors then you can
have this sort of a frozen configuration
for intolerance so basically if you want
to do clobber dynamics you have to
remove the color of one vertex and
recolor it there's only one possible
choice so if you do proper dynamics this
configuration will just freeze it cannot
go anywhere so this is the sort of
problem when the Markov chain approach
will stop to work and it's contracted to
be the circled but as we all know the
Markov chain is not the only method
right we have these all these
deterministic counting algorithms as
well so we can do the so-called
corrosion decay matter this was first
there are by commanding cuts for this
problem that if Q is not related to some
alpha times Delta plus beta where Peter
is large and offered roughly 2.8 184
then you can do deterministic counting
based on the current decay method so
basically do some kind of recursive
algorithm and Kincaid and this was
improved by luan in to alpha roughly two
point five eight on the other hand we
can also do these zeros of polynomial
method or the method of of many names
yeah say okay so this method at first
but now the message is a quasi problem
time but but Iraq's made it so really
polynomial time and so a direct
consequence of this result is that you
can do is for Q larger than alpha times
Delta
okay something like six times six point
nine one this comes from earlier paper
from Jackson procs proxy so Co I think
yeah and this was recently improved to
kill early times data due to punch
Terri's Patel reacts but I guess is fair
to say that that we cannot match the
randomized algorithm that is not yet
okay so that's pretty much what we know
about determine is about counting
tolerance so we have some happiness we
have some result already a lot but they
are not quite the same yet but she is in
the on the same order right it's just we
can't have the passage constant to get
okay so what I'm really gonna talk about
these hyper graph colorings so I move on
to hyper graphs and the coloring I'm
working with is sort of a week covering
where I only want to forbid
monochromatic edges okay so this is a
again pictorial proof no edge is
monochromatic
these boxes are hyper edges and so what
about hyper car have epic are colorings
it also called studied and you can do
Markov chain and path coupling ceteris a
ball which tire and Karpinski
on like more than ten years ago
that the global dynamics is again
roughly mixing if say I have a K uniform
have a graph with K is lambda equal to
four and the Q larger Delta okay goes
through a key like that one point five
dot right so it seems a lot better than
counting colorings in graphs because
well I mean we spend so much time to
improve a constant and here you saw a
kept constant one for most cases however
although it looks like better but it's
actually much worse because we know that
if you apply lavash lock lemma which I
will talk about in more details later if
you apply professional climber then the
existence of heroine will be guaranteed
as long as Q is at least something
roughly Delta to the one over K minus
one so it's actually even if Q is much
less than Delta they are still they
still is prob coloring and so this Delta
G cannot be the right answer
and indeed this was also so further
pushed by phrase and his collaborators
Friesen must at the give an example when
someone Q is a much less than Delta then
they exist a soft frozen carbon where no
move is possible and indeed their result
is a malayalam result but this is of
just consequence sorry a side note that
they are two is these frozen colorings
for Markov chain approach and
nonetheless the results of freezer mass
that is algorithmic and it's got
improved later by freezing the Anastos
they show that global dynamics is still
converges rapidly although there are
frozen configurations but the they have
some very strong collisions so the the
palm down q so the second term here is
roughly matches roughly match is the
Delta to the 1 over K minus 1 so that's
very good
but the assume the hypergraph is simple
so which means average to have red
insect in at most one vertex so this is
very strong restriction and also they
requires a number of colors to be at
least log in so it cannot be constantly
colors so although my coaching approach
still can work but it has some drawbacks
so our result on the other hand we don't
get to the best constant look at some
terrible constant here so it's like the
other two the fourth hangover came
exporting and also we need a K to be
really large or and a huge constant here
but the point is we don't have any
further assumptions this is our only
assumption and this is the constant so
this is by no means they the correct
answer but we can't opt back we'll try
to off now with this but this is
basically what we caught oh I don't know
how to operate it further also we get a
polynomial time approximation scheme
which is deterministic or wisdom to
count the number of q colorings came in
from a half graph maximum degree tip dot
and somewhat interestingly in these
regimes you cannot do self reducibility
well the reason in coloring norm
coloring the condition we have is
something like Q over Delta is a larger
angle some alpha and the one we do self
reducibility when ping versus one by one
right say if a neighbor of a vertex
called pinged you can effectively remove
one color from that vertex you get some
kind of list coloring so this would
imply that humans 1 over Delta minus 1
will still be learning to have okay so
the these properties are also preserved
on the Selfridge
reductions but here because Q is much
less than the other you actually cannot
afford to this so somehow the some
reduce may self with usability done told
anymore we need to spend some extra time
to get a almost uniform sampler
and also we need to have some what was
constants and as I said earlier the
method that we use is completely
different from correlation decay and you
know by me knocks methods and he's sort
of a more refined version of a method of
Moitra and it's closely related to the
lavash law claim and basically our
original motivation is to understand
more trials method we try to understand
the words easy central and water
insoluble and necessary and indeed we
saw get rid of one auxiliary process of
mantra and if you have the origin in the
original approach you because he had
this all glory thing he would have a
extra condition but we sort of got rid
of this and this condition only involves
K and Delta naught Q but we don't need
this okay so that's the result and the
question so far I had I haven't tried
the DeRose but I tried a little bit of
writing the recursion force of corrector
decay and this cannot be quite
complicated they don't get a clean as
clean recursion as the trough case so I
don't know how to make other seem to
work all right so I will move on to tell
you about what this algorithm is about
how it relates to the wash low climber
so okay this is a warm-up so the what
what is the local Emma we have seen low
climber in among day due to his
connection to Independence polynomials
in monitor Young's talk let me remind
you what local ama is so the in fact the
very original local Emma was used to
show the existence of three colorings
they have a graph so this is already two
designed to tackle this problem and in
general we have or some have graph and
will lead to the neighborhood of a hyper
edge
we all that is that intersecting this
edge and thus the because of the great
bone we have the size of neighborhood it
at most some times alpha minus 1 times
okay
and I will be particularly interested in
this so called asymmetric form of the
local imma do to lavage
that so we give some numbers so every
hyper edge and the condition we want is
the probability of under product
distribution the probability of the
Hebrides monochromatic is that most
these numbers times 1 minus of these
numbers in the neighborhood if this
holds for every average than the proper
color exists okay and the normally we
set these numbers to something like 1
over K times Delta and this is rather
easy to work out that this quantity on
the right hand side is lower bounded by
1 over e times K times Delta and the
left hand side because the his product
distribution is just a you know cube
possibility of monochromatic
configurations and the total probability
so possibility is Q to the K to get a 1
over Q document
so this recovers the condition I
mentioned earlier Q it's at least ek
Delta to the 1 over K minus 1 so as long
as this holds that we have a proper
color so the first thing first useful
thing of this is that we can use it to
reduce computer sort of counting to
computing marginal probabilities as I
said earlier the self reducibility
doesn't really work anymore but we can
use the local I'm advanced solve a CUDA
partial coloring and we try to compare
to the marginal probability of this good
part of coloring so this is what happy
note by Tao and what we want is that
every hyper edge is satisfied by its
first some k1 vertices I give an
arbitrary ordinary of the verses so this
will succeed is very easy application
locally mother this is what succeed as
long as kids are done basically I
replace K by this k1
and the KY eventually will be said some
cells would be something like K or 14 so
we're paying this with pings some small
fraction of the verses in each hyper
edge and then we try to compute the
marginal probability of this partial
coloring so let's say this is our vs.
that hanged and the MU is the uniform
distribution so the probability that a
random coloring is consistent with this
towel is just Q to the N minus RR being
the size of the coloring divided by all
number of colorings and that you can
sort of easily write this as a
telescoping product and the our
algorithm we were just estimated this
marginal probability is 1 by 1 so
effectively we won't estimate marginal
probabilities under some partial
colorings that we'll use some of the
verses but not all of the vertices okay
this is a good said I won't ask me all
these marginal probabilities up to
something like 1 over epsilon over an
arrow because I will modify graphics and
things here that's a nice applications
that you can reduce counting to
computing modular probabilities all
those separate those built a ton quite
work
okay another nice thing about local EMA
is that you can actually prove something
about the uniform distribution using the
lock line and again this sees the set of
all colorings and the meal is the
uniform distribution effectively you can
think of me as a product distribution
conditional there's no model chromatic
edits and the the local I'm a cure
controls this conditional distribution
in that if the collision hold a
symmetric condition holds therefore any
event the probability of this event in
the conditional distribution is that
most the product distribution multiplied
by some correction terms and this
correction term is something 1 over 1
minus X of e where e so this even P will
depend on some set of vertices and the
even this high priority is e are just
those intersecting this set of vertices
and this is a 72 Hoffler zahaan
Srinivasan so basically we can keep
upper bound on the any event in this
conditional distribution of course we
concave lower bound because we don't
limit the some of the bad events right
okay so we have these upper bounds
what's this useful to us um in fact
using this which is it rather you just
see that under any partial coloring the
vertices each marginal probability for
any vertex is that very very close to
uniform okay so I have some assumptions
say this exercise is something between K
and K prime because we will be operating
on their partial colorings so we need
some look so the size of the hybrid will
decrease but not too much and I have
some parameter T which will pick later
okay I have this sort of condition or
local I might have condition then I can
show that the marginal probability is is
roughly 1 over Q but with some error
like some constant over T
something I can choose so to prove this
is very easy you prove upper bound is
just a direct application of the lemma I
showed you last slide and to give a
lower bound that you just give upper
bound for solve the block in cases
blocking cases are where you have all
the verses having this color see and
then you use a Union bound on all these
have writers so basically this control
the version of the low climber gives us
local uniformity and eventually we will
set this T to be something like the
other to the C and our condition is
something like this so if you plug in
Delta C will give you something like
this so what that was I have I have that
under the uniform distribution all
vertices are very close uniform but this
is really nonsense right because they
are really just unit for all colors are
symmetric what's really useful of this
is that when I have some partial
colorings some of verses are already
colored but at least I have K prime many
so they're still available then I can
control the uniformity locally for each
marginal probability so the K prime is
something that came out K 1 and so this
is very nice it tells us something about
the marginal probability but it's not
good enough right our go is something
like 1 cosmo absent over an
approximation this gives us some
constant approximation so it's not good
enough
the really magic is so we can bootstrap
this into a very good approximation okay
so that I will need to define a sort of
coupling process the algorithm itself is
completely deterministic is essentially
a linear programming or wisdom but
somehow the margins are the variables
from the in the linear program comes
from this coupling process although we
don't really run this company process we
don't know how to write okay so let's
say I want to compute the marginal
probability of some vertex V and C sub I
will be the
set up colorings where these given color
I am Eli's uniform overseas I so what we
want to do is that we want cover me one
in the middle to so as vertex V we have
this courtesy and we want to in some
some way called Cobb overseas one by one
so that we get to some boundaries at ha
so nice all the constraints are
satisfied so the process is something
like this so I start with the
descriptive e1 will always be
discrepancies
so at first I have one vertex I will
maintain some set of colored vertices
and the rest of v2 is the rest of the
verses we monthly one and for each hyper
edge so they're still intersecting
between v1 v2 I will try to cut over the
first vertex of that and I will cover
the maximally assuming the margin profit
is unknown of course I don't know that
and I cannot run happening but let's
assume we can do that now I know that
because the local uniformity I know the
marginal probability is close to uniform
so whatever the c1 c2 we can cover it
with very low error and whenever a high
priority is satisfied in post copies and
remove it and whenever a have had too
many color you know happy are too many
vertices are colored then I will put all
of the rest as if I fail the whole edge
although these vertices are not colored
yet but I will think of the mag failed I
put them in v1 and that again will
remove that and when all the hair
prodigy in second v1 are removed I will
stop so oh and this constant k2 will
eventually set something like 3k over
seven yeah so this seems quite abstract
and I have a example okay so this is my
hyper graph and I started with some
vertex B at first I have two different
colors blue and sorry green and red and
then the we had we have these hyper edge
and I will color the first vertex okay
maybe I'm not lucky I got right here
and blue here although these have rarely
satisfied this one is not so I will not
remove the hyper edge and also as let's
say I won't only cover color two verses
out of the four so I will put to the
rest of them as if they are they were
filled although I haven't tried to cup
of them at all okay so all of them will
be in v1 because I have meet my fair
hold and then I will continue to do this
okay now I have looking at these
heritage maybe I'm lucky
oh I am NOT lucky in that I don't get
same color but I'm lucky both copies
they have really said fine and I will
remove it and then I will look at this
approach know I'm lucky I got same color
and I'm sorry these high pressures this
hybrid called satisfied in both and this
guy
I have same color so we want done the
increase anymore and okay I remove it
and I will look at this vertex again
let's say I'm lucky a cup same color
however this hyper edge although the
colors are the same they are not
satisfied and also I meet my limit I
have colored two vertices I will put the
rest of them in the fields in the
discrepancies set so the although this
is this remaining vertex is not colored
I still put it in v1 and I still have
have rated intersecting we want to beat
you namely these two have edges okay now
continue maybe I'm not very lucky I
called same colors in color and
satisfied they removed okay that's how
the having process goes and basically
because of local uniformity you can show
that as long as you have some empty
verses in these high varieties and the
queue is started as some kind of local
I'm not hyped condition then the
coupling will stop in Dorgan steps with
a very high power bid well the
intuitively because each vertex you have
a very small probability to be to have a
discrepancy at this equipment and the
sort of branching factor is something
like the other times K so
some kind of parenting process will stop
very quickly and so this is basically
we're seeing that different from our
approach and Moitra moisture more
multi-max what's to couple in advance so
he first ran some mock process some
process to mark versus to be coupled and
then to the copying process whereas our
having some adaptive we do this on the
fly but this is our main difference okay
all right so one way to think about this
coupling is that is some kind of a tree
right you start with some partial
colorings at has x and y and it has Q
square many children's possibilities to
color the next vertex which we have
enough by you so basically you have cube
choices for each coffee you have Q
square many so this gives us some
coupling tree and the really nice thing
is that we can read on some linear
program according to this tree so we
cannot run coupling the coupling
requires us to know the marginal
probabilities we don't know that is that
we will set up a linear program
something like this okay so the
definition looks a bit strange this is
mu Cabo XY it basically the probability
you see X comma Y in that inter coupling
process and the expert of this is x cos
x CX this is actually the probability
that conditioned on C in X in the other
coffee you see Y and this is the other
way around yeah this CX CY also the
number of the set of colorings that are
consistent with X on Y one first thing
to notice is these are really
probabilities if you sum them you get
one and yeah we're some of them is
basically the probability that here you
get X you sum over all Y so that is
exactly CX over c1
so the the next thing we are going to do
is that we will write linear programs of
these of these variables
and then we will do some kind of binary
search to solve for the real ratio
between C 1 C 2 this is all about it
so C 1 C 2 can be write this form is
just from definition and the nice
observation is that whenever coupling
stops is a leaf in the coupling tree
then we can compute this CX / cy in time
exponential in the uncolored vertices
within v1 and we sort of know the
coupling process will stop in logon
steps with high probability so almost
always we have a fold to this the first
constraints are eventually we'll set of
binary search so the first constraints
are cast so the lower bound and upper
bound for c1 over c2 this is what we
want to solve really well we will do
binary search find and these are the
first constraints who will base with
guess a lower bound guess are bound that
will read this for all the internal x y
of all the leaf XY and the second
constraints are so very important these
are so flow kind constraints so as I
said the this you can think of this a
traditional singing X 0 it was probably
there saying Y so at the first in the
root you have only one vertex you of
course that probably have seen in the
other one is one but for every non leaf
perhaps in the coupling tree it has many
children's and if you sum over all the
possibilities on the Y side it's
effectively you see why we thought of
the you colored so you get actually the
probability of px over the X version of
px X Y so these are these are sort of
flow constraint so all of these all of
these children where you know why coffee
get some color with some to this
and similarly on the Y side so why this
useful so we do to this cell flow kind
of constraint for any given Sigma a
coloring that he where vert has vCard
the one if we sum over all the leaves
will X so it's all the leaving incoming
tree is just a pair of partial colorings
where X is consistent with Sigma if you
sum over all of them is just the one due
to the flow kind of constraint so now we
can rewrite CY the sum of ones and
therefore its some of these guys see
this right this is the sum over all the
leaves of this px XY times the number of
currents consistent with CX and
therefore we can get the ratio is
exactly this sum but due to the first
constraint we know that each term of
this is between the lower caste lower
and upper bound therefore the ratio you
c1c2 must be between the lower and upper
bound so this is how the what's called
soundness of the program's the of course
they already if the test lower and upper
bound are correct than the true values
of these PX x wise will certified
program and if the program is satisfied
then the true ratio will be between our
upper and the lower bound so we can set
up a binary search find this ratio and
when we get to the ratio for every path
colors we can get the marginal
probability however this is not the end
because as you can imagine the linear
program will have to run ho coupling the
coupling has very high probability
terminating log and traps but it will
but it is not necessary of log in size
so it can be expenditure large so but we
know it's term is quickly so we can do
truncation we truncated add some kind of
log in steps so this words of these
local uniformity comes in we will write
the last kind of constraints so
basically is saying
in I have some X&Y the next step I will
color you but you got different colors C
and the C Prime
but because the local uniformity I
always maintain I know the error is that
most something like five over T and this
quantity venture you said something like
Delta to a six so we have this third
kind of constraint because of a local
uniformity we will guarantee the
truncation will not give us too much
error and also we know that the true
value will satisfy this
so the truncation error comes from this
say again in the previous scene we solve
the right side of c1 as sum of all their
sum of all some of ones of the each of
these colorings and each one can be
written as is formed so we will truncate
some those none of those leaves that are
too deep in the coupling tree will be
truncated
some advantage from this some so the
truncation error comes from conditioning
on this Sigma the coupling will run for
too long so you have too many deep
leaves however this could happen for
example if Sigma has the first half
verses for every average to be
monochromatic then now if the add will
be removed because its monochromatic so
the coupling will just run for sort of
until everything is colored the such
kind of bad colorings do exist yeah
that's what I said
say so what we prove is two things first
the fraction of this back having is
small so basically that can only happen
when all the early versatile
monochromatic so if you color
sufficiently large fraction of early
verses you will not in being in this
situation and then second thing is for
every good color in the criteria error
is small this is due to the third
constraint
um yes so this is a again the one that
sells so bad coloring must fail many
have rarities during covering step and
we cup of some kind of K 2 vertices
forever for every hyper edge so of
course you were small if Kate who is
large and the error comes from these
local uniformity is called so k2 is a
number of verses we color in each hair
at say local uniformity is content
controlled by the empty vertices which
is kept here K prime minus K G and we'll
keep her mental kid who is large that we
know the versatile clothes the uniform
so somehow we need to balance these two
effects so essentially we yeah in the
end we set up a of medicine to get the
best constant but it turns out that K 2
is just half of K Prime yeah so that's
the way how we get our constant and yeah
this finish of the whole I'm sorry this
finishes computing the marginal
probabilities and ok this is not quite
the end we have shown use of how to
compute to how to approximate counting
by reducing to computing model
probabilities or this is what I said I
will find a clue the partial coloring I
will compute the marginal probability of
that for something we need to do
something slightly different we will use
the marginal to color vertices but we
will do something similar to a coupling
process we color some fraction of verses
for every high branch and we show that
with high probability if you color this
many verses that all the remaining
connected components have logarithmic
size so is some isolated connected
components and for each component you
just brute force color it this is
because the dog sighs you just have no
more time
well and the all these algorithms are
deterministic you solve a linear program
is deterministic when you fund this
partial coloring you need to use the
already me conversion of local Emma
it has some randomized version we can
use of course something cannot be
deterministic I think that's all about
the Autism Center here some remarks the
first question that's in my mind is
what's the right thread hold okay so my
personal guess is something like Delta
to the two over K but basically
currently we are still very far away
from this for coloring in graphs we know
is roughly Delta but we don't know how
what's the past constant for hyper
graphs we don't even know what's the
correct order okay my guess is this this
is because the reason I guess this is
because for hypergraph I didn't set
something like this basically is the
square of the lavash local I'm a bound
is a correct answer
however I don't really have any evidence
for this because I don't even know who
the and the hani's proof for sampling
hypergraph colorants okay you can prove
some honeys but it will be nowhere near
this sort of us are hold at is I don't
know how to prove let's say the other
two the one over K kind of their hope
and the resistance of a two of two
questions
so first is can we use this method for
normal graph colorings currently we have
this constant times Delta result and if
you use this method just naively you can
some polynomial in doubt so that's not
good but maybe you can optimize this
somewhat um to get better so at his
competing bound for competing against
like origin decay of all zeros or
polynomials on the other hand we can we
do something about the zeros of hyper
graph colorants this is also something I
don't know corrida case seems to be
hopeless because the current is
really complicated I don't know how to
deal with that but maybe zeros is mob
and that's it thank you questions or
remarks
concerns suggestions 15 any results
field final questions in the simple
hydrographic case that's a cool question
I haven't thought about that same way
you Nina yes be that you might expect
some of the graph methods to carry over
in that right right yeah that's a good
point
um my suspicion for simple you don't get
this you should prove the cattail so one
over came as well so basically the
phrase a poor result by without today
you know log in haven't thought about
mother whistles
now let us thank the speaker again and
we reconvene at 11:00